this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday february the 23rd the joint is
brought to you one of my [__]
favorites liquid iv listen i know you're
thinking about getting that summer body
ready for beet season but make sure you
got a little liquid iv in that gym bag i
got to be honest with you i've been
they've been my sponsor for a couple
months
i didn't really know what liquid iv
brought to the table until i got covered
and now i am hooked one stick of liquid
iv
in 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
than water alone anything else it's made
with premium ingredients liquid iv is
vegan non-gmo and free of gluten dairy
and soy
support and front line workers over 19
million
servings donated so far but listen
liquid iv is tremendous whether it's the
passion fruit the cherry the acai it
comes in three different formula
formulas energy immune and the regular
and i like all of them
immune i drank the hell out of when i
had the covenant it was tremendous so if
you're looking to hydrate and you're
looking to get your body in tip top
magoo just for the joint listeners get
25 off when you go to liquid iv.com and
use promo code joey if you go to one of
the supermarkets you're going to be
paying a lot
i'm going to get you 25 off when you go
to liquidity.com
and use promo code joey at checkout
you're gonna love it start off with the
grape or the cherry that's 25 off
anything you order when you order promo
code joey at liquidity.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com
the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen
how many times i got to say about cbd
lion it's the best i'm on the tinctures
and i sleep like a [__] baby and when
i need to sleep i'll pop a couple of
those cbd gummies oh my god the tropical
fruit ones with the melatonin you'll
sleep like a foot when when the alarm
goes off you'll be thinking you're in
[__] mars cbd lion the best cbd on
the market go to cbdline.com right now
read learn about cbd cbn cby
press joey joint the church and get 20
off on the best cbd on the market today
go to
cbdline.com and press joey and get 20
off delivered right to your
[__] house and the joint is
also brought to you by
expressvpn you've heard me talk about
how important it is to have vpn to
protect your online privacy but choosing
a vpn you trust is equally as important
now you know uncle joey only recommends
what i [__] believe in i can say with
full confidence
that expressvpn
is the number one on the market here's
why expressvpn doesn't lock your
activity online lots of cheap vpns sell
your data advertisers but not expressvpn
it's faster than ever streaming hd with
zero buffering and it's simple you don't
need any technical skills if i could do
it you could do it and it's not just for
me saying this business inside of the
verge and others rate expressvpn the
number one
vpn in the world i'm telling you if you
want to look for creepy things this is
the way to go so protect yourself with
the vpn that i use and trust
expressvpn.com
joey today and get an extra three months
for free on the one year package that's
express
slash vpn.com again
expressvpn.com
joey to learn more and now without
further ado the joint is coming at you
tip
top magoo
hey how you doing
come
on welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
my
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint wednesday the 23rd
of [__] february it's been a
great week so far yesterday
[__] monday it was like 60 [__]
degrees yesterday was like 60 degrees it
rained
so it's [__] springtime in new jersey
but don't get your [__] uh
don't put your winter jackets away yet
[__] but anyway i'm good it's
been a great [__] week so far a lot
of years watched that uh i know a lot of
you saw
the video that [__] lee posted on
saturday for my birthday great job great
video
i gotta tell you something that video
even shocked
the [__] out of me it really did
lee looked like a million [__] bucks
i have not seen him
since uh we left la i'm gonna see him in
uh
three weeks and i'm really [__]
excited to see him we're gonna get
together on a sunday mike's gonna come
up he'll get some chinese food you know
he'll come in like friday night
i'll do something with him saturday you
know he doesn't want to do much leave
but it's amazing
how one i miss him and number two
i'm really [__] proud of him i'm i
and guys
i always knew it
you know i tell you guys a big [__]
lie i go listen when i got into comedy
i didn't want to be on tv or any of that
stuff i didn't
but i got to tell you something the only
thing that made me stay there was my
belief i had a [__] strange belief
that something could happen if i told my
story and it did i was correct but at
the same time i had a weird feeling
about lee
i knew lee was gonna do great things
it was just to get out of that [__]
we were just caught in a [__]
continuing hole and it was brought on by
ourselves
now that i think about it i see you know
what we put into the church but listen
what i put into the church and what i
put into the joint is two different
energies the church
we didn't know what we were going with
we didn't know what we wanted to do and
it became bigger than we knew what to do
with it like i
i think now how big numbers were
compared to the show now and like i
listen i'm not upset by it at all we all
have to evolve people move on you know
howard stern wasn't going to be the king
of the airways forever that proved you
know now it's joe rogan you know he's
the king of the [__] airways but
i always understood the evolution of it
but i knew i wasn't giving up i knew i
wasn't stopping i'll tell you one thing
now now
i feel that whatever we were going
through the last two years
is over with
so now it's time to [__] go for it
you know we've all been
pretty uh we've accepted things the last
two years and nobody has accepted things
more than i have
and guess what i don't like what i
accepted i really don't i accepted a lot
of mediocrity
and it was the best i could do at the
time and uh
you know my 50
is better than some people's 100 percent
but
my mind wasn't right and all that's
behind us now so now
i'm on a [__] mission to be as
good as i could be
you know i don't know what the future's
gonna bring i don't know
but i do know i'm happy
i do know that i'm enjoying my time here
i know that um
there's a lot going on in the world and
i don't give a [__] about it no more
like it's just i'm concerned with you
guys my patreon
my house my wife my kids and that's it
that's it mike his family the people
that are close to me you know you can't
help everybody i'm not in a on a big
forum anymore like i used to be in
california
i'm in [__] new jersey in a little
[__] hellhole and guess what
i'm enjoying it so this week after i saw
that
uh
video for lee i i just said you know
what man it was funny how many people
said happy birthday to me and i
appreciate
all the well wishes and the happy
birthdays but i gotta tell you something
i got just as many messages from my
birthday
as i did about lee
people were like we cannot believe how
good he looks we cannot believe
the twinkle in his eye is back you know
and i lost my twinkle in my eye too i
saw some of those old
church videos and yeah we were having
fun and we were laughing but i tell you
what the twinkle in my eye was gone i
was burnt out and it's okay to be burnt
out
and
the hard thing about being burnt out is
acknowledging it
is everything you never really know
when you're in it you know but
all that's behind us now you know i'm
happy that you guys are still on board
uh watching us some people have moved on
i wish them all well but we're making a
[__] strong comeback here you know
and hopefully in a while we'd get a
[__] like i stopped looking like
during the pandemic but now i'm back on
it i'm really interested
in a small studio we could [__] smoke
up and yell and scream and tell people
to suck my [__] and have people banging
on the door stop smoking weed i miss all
that [__] that i do miss
and we'll figure it out but for right
now man i got you uh we had a bust out
of zoom this week i know you guys aren't
big on the zooms but i had a bust went
out and we're gonna bust one out the
next couple podcasts because uncle joey
can't do all this [__] talking on
himself i can't until we get something
going here i just can't but uh today i
bring you the beauty
of mr lee syed enjoy [__]
[Music]
what's up you bad [__] look at
you how's it going buddy you're
deteriorating to nothing and [__] you
think you're funny with that [__]
video the hummus got you huh
oh it was too much you're not supposed
to eat a spoonful of hummus that doesn't
make the medicine go down that [__]
spicy hummus tastes like a hindus
[__] toast
after he [__] runs two miles in
[__] india with the covert invest
with the [__] cover there god knows
what else hummus
when was the last time you ate hummus
before that
too long almost like a little bit every
once in a while but and the flies
started attacking you you see that you
have no flies around you anymore they
were trying to say there was a fly on
your neck
but i was like these [__] i
think it was i think it was it must have
been you there haven't been a fly since
i left l.a i mean it's the hummus like i
told you
when you need hummus it comes out of
your [__] pores as [__]
what what the what do flies like the
most [__]
oh do you ever see a piece of [__] take
a piece of [__] how long do the fly
lands on it [__] two seconds and then
he whistles for his [__] friends and
his family and they all attack that
piece of [__] till they get down to the
[__] granola bit
i forgot you used to like have flies as
pets and like do science experiments on
flies now flies don't even come around
me because you're not around see they
knew i was related to you
by [__] proxy even though you didn't
suck my dick and i didn't suck yours but
thank god they [__]
i can't even catch i don't even see a
[__] fly no more i was thinking about
that i found the can the other day my
little fly paradise
you took that home you took that from to
new jersey you brought that yeah i
worked hard on that little [__] fly
getaway and [__]
that's my little fly getaway i had a
pond in there some thc deposits and [__]
i had a [__] room where they could
just hang themselves like a little rope
and [__] like just
it got too much the thc got too much
oh my god that's so crazy what are you
down now tarzan
144. jesus christ and what are you going
for
uh i want to get down to 150 so that's
another 40 pounds
and how much walking are you still doing
four times a week i do about
at least three miles no [__] how does it
take you
right now 45 minutes to an hour it's
really not that bad like i do i do it on
the walk with my patreon we just talk
and it's uh i actually like walking now
i i'm never gonna be a hiker or like a
huge working working out person but a
little walk it it clears my mind
i it's it's fun that's why i like the
city more i like being able to like oh
i'm gonna go walk to the store now
in la you're walking and looking at dirt
and homeless people it's boring
it's funny because
you used to always say that the reason
why you put on so much weight in l.a was
beside the edibles the weed the hummus
the [__] uh you know the
the cheese covered fries and [__]
was to not walking
and i just came on a
couple months you know i went back to
jiu jitsu and i noticed that my cardio
was [__] again and you know you lift
weights
you do kettlebells you try to do
everything you can i don't even know
what cardio is and then i started
reading
when i joined jiu jitsu and then i got
to covet i started reading those days i
had to covert
and ever since uh
i don't know the last week of december
i've been walking on a treadmill
and it's so weird how you find out a lot
about yourself because
i never looked at walking as anything
big i did it for [__] years in new
york walked from
port authority to 150 that's 40 [__]
blocks you know right that's a long
[__] that's a long one i used to do
that all the time i was a big time
walker
but i realized when i started walking
again and leave do you have a whoop
watch
i i don't i don't you gotta get a
[__] watch
okay whatever it is a month 30 bucks a
month whatever i got to tell you man i'm
learning more about myself every [__]
day and every day it's a challenge like
you have to beat the record from
yesterday
and that's the one that tracks your
workout your sleep attracts everything
that's your workout your sleep with your
sleep is important it you know it works
on your [__] vitals your oxygen your
heart rate
you know for me being a [__] old goat
i like it and it works i never thought
that when i got it it was a friend
referred it to me at jiu jitsu and i got
to tell you man you learn a lot
like i think i'm working out hard but
you ain't doing [__]
like
and then you go home and put the watch
on and you're like [__] 4.4
what the [__] and they'll tell you you
went to lyft but you did more cardio
based stuff so
get back to lifting you know and it just
really i like to sleep on it
like now i'm learning to [__] go to
bed early i keep my cuz they'll tell you
go to bed at 11 13
and wake up at 7 48. they'll tell you
right they'll tell you what you need
what your body needs water it's [__]
pretty intense but man
i almost got as much as i my to godly
and this is why i called you yesterday i
said i got as many happy birthdays as i
got
did you see lee
my facebook had about 20 messages and 10
of them were
were really happy for lee you know now i
heard you got a podcast with the
girlfriend it's funny
oh yeah we just did we did an episode
about going to philly to eat but now
yeah i i appreciate it man it's um
you you were always in a nice way on me
about working out eating right and
i'm i wish i wish i had an answer to
this but i feel i honestly feel like
every person just has to be there
because i just wasn't
i just wasn't ready i guess because it's
just i've been on it for
14 months
and
i'm not doing really anything
that's special i honestly the walking is
the working out i do i threw my back out
doing kettlebells and i don't do that
anymore
and
i have
regular meals it's just
i got this is the lightest i've been
probably since high school
and i'm just i like it i'm down to a 36
now i've i was i was over 50 inch waist
when i left la
i was at i stopped at a walmart in
arkansas or wherever the head of walmart
is and i had to buy the biggest jeans
they had and they barely fit
and now i'm down to a 36 and like even
steve simone and jimmy schubert they
took me walking when when we were still
in l.a during cover we went walking a
couple times a week i had to sit down on
the street i hated it
just little changes man i mean look at
you i i just like i told you yesterday i
just watched the sopranos movie you were
so much bigger back then
you lost a ton of weight too i bet
you know it looks like i lost weight but
it's deceiving i'm putting on weight as
we [__] speak i've gained like 10
pounds since the coven is it muscle do
you think
i don't have a muscle in my [__] body
i'm an old [__] geezer but
i don't know what it is you know i
i've been eating the edibles again and
some of them like the all the delta
eights have
that sugar on them and [__] sugar is my
[__] enemy i mean sure is everybody's
enemy between the inflammation and the
weight i could eat 22 [__] pork chops
and not gain as much weight as i eat one
[__] donut that's what [__] me over
it's ridiculous like the sugar levels
and i avoid it as much as you can but
let's face it everything's got sugar in
it you avoid going out to eat a lot but
you still got to break down and go out
to eat sometimes when you go out to eat
you got to look at the menu and say
you know i look at my meat intake a lot
i really take a look at my meat intake
you know and we all as young men people
watch this podcast
we're all [__] big time meat eaters
you know what i'm gonna tell you
something i [__] couldn't imagine
a life without a [__] steak
you know i love steak everybody loves
steak but for me
i eat i eat any meat after like six
o'clock at night it's a [__]
nightmare for me what happened who eats
a steak at ten lunchtime you know
i don't it just i gotta watch my meat
intake and you'll see guys
you know i went to a a friend of mine i
don't mean to insult him heavyset dude
great guy one of my best friends in
jersey
keep sending me to and this is i i want
to tell people this
he sent me to the marlboro diner for the
uh hash brown skillet how good does that
sound
a hash brown [__] skillet does it
have like eggs on top and stuff eggs and
bacon dog it's got eggs
hash browns too you can't eat them no
more
and it's ham bacon
and what's the other breakfast thing
people eat sausage sausage ham breakfast
sausage
they put the three eggs on top and then
they cover all the [__] cheese now
if we're talking we're smoking dope and
we're talking
it's it's a great thing wow you can get
that you know uh there's a bagel place
bagel world on the 520. i [__] love
them
that whole mall is gold
they got pliable
which is like coconut milk instead of
acai bowl on the bottom with granola and
[__] they got red tomato pie the tomato
pizza over there it's delicious
they got a chicken place that's
delicious but the place i like the most
over there they got a seven seas chinese
restaurant that's [__]
tremendous but bagel world has a
sandwich lee he can't even [__]
finish it
it's got two eggs
cheese a hash brown
sausage bacon
ham and something else for the [__]
jews
you know and it's like this
so i looked at it then i asked the guy i
go you saw a lot of these
dog a ton of them and i didn't get the
words out of my mouth a woman ordered
two of them and then
she was eating one of them like she was
[__] she wasn't even chubby or
nothing she was just a regular woman a
workout chick but she ate the whole
[__] thing
you know and when you look at those
dishes when you're 22
28 31 when you smoke dope those dishes
are really attractive
but i went down there and i ate that
thing and i had [__] diarrhea
and it was good
but it's a batman dish
it was so good it overwhelmed me like
the meat was good the ham was good
everything was good i only ate half of
it but it was so overwhelming i had to
run home and [__] my [__] blew up
i heard noises and bones hitting the
[__] toilet
i would have destroyed the [__] my
tushy but
uh
it was so weird how i made i go it was
good
it was really good if you're 22 31 you
know 29 and you hung over you got your
dick sucks he sucked all to come out of
your dick you need some food but it
wasn't for me at 58.
like it just wasn't for me i have you in
my head man because i got i got to be
honest the last month or so
i've been sort of going back and forth i
i [__] up in december i took like
christmas off and i gained like i gained
14 pounds in 14 days and i lost it all i
got back on the thing
but
it's
i have you in my head where in l.a when
i used to eat that [__] you used to tell
me like hey man
if you're gonna eat chinese wait till
you go back to boston if you're gonna go
eat this like make have it be worth it
and
it that's the way i cuz
like even with steak like you're just
talking about steak i had steak the
other night but i could have i know you
have chicken breasts with weight
watchers
a chicken breast is a few couple hundred
few hundred calories a steak the same
size is almost a thousand calories
it's like is it really yeah i like a
steak but is it really worth it should i
and that's why i know you you give me
[__] about the ground turkey
i have like i'm
i want to lose this last 40 pounds
and then see what i can do because
that's gonna i've never been able to
keep it off lee you're looking for
that's what he's
like a [__] aids
slash cancer victim you know whatever
i'm supposed to be all you need to do is
shave your eyebrows and people be giving
you free meals and bells and whistles
and [__] you can take your race
i'll take a trip to disney world
drop 20 and see how you feel drop 20
more and see how you feel
because you're getting [__] skinny
yeah i'm 190 right now i haven't been
why i haven't been under 200 in a long
goddamn time
i get pretty much
pretty much i was in a diaper at 190.
it's like the honeymoon is when ralph
goes no and did you send me pictures of
me when i weighed 300 pounds and he goes
no i never did see any of your baby
pictures
oh that's a great [__] joke yeah no
it was true dude i was
i was huge at the end i just couldn't
between i just couldn't stop and that
and i still have it in me like i saw
in december when i took that break i
have to really be strict with myself
because i can't if i have a cheat day or
let myself go off the tracks i i [__] i
still have it
i i can still eat like i used to eat
listen we're [__] human man we're
humanly
and i got to be honest with you so you
don't feel too bad about yourself
[__] i was great last year i really
was i i did as good as a job as i could
i watch my weight i watch what i ate
[__] i had covetly and i don't know
what happened and people gonna laugh at
me when they hear this story
my daughter had a box of [__] candy
upstairs
well i tell you it's a box guys
i got no reason to lie to you it's she
had a crate
from halloween from halloween we had to
break it up and get rid of it and i
don't know if it was my my wife what too
much can i think of my wife bought too
much candy but it was just stacks of
[__] uh
what's that [__] uh reese's root oh baby
okay reese's
a [__] three musketeers hundred
thousand dollar bar
the licorice
what's it called the red one the cherry
twizzler twizzler and the little packs
oh yeah the [__] little peanut butter
cups i would go upstairs when i had to
comb it
and fill
my pouch my hooded sweatshirt
with [__] and i couldn't that's never
been me like it hasn't been me since i
was you know 20 every once in a while i
go off the deep end lee if i tell you
that was
from the 23rd of [__] december every
night till like the second of january
i couldn't stop i couldn't [__] stop
by midnight i'd have to go upstairs i
just fill my pot and i was picky too
like yeah babe roots i would [__]
devour oh she had those more balls
all the whoppers
god damn
so i went to the same thing you went
through and i ballooned from the sugar
it wasn't even i was eating
ice cream or doughnuts nothing literally
enterman's is done
really [__] uh dunkin donuts is done
i mean doughnuts does why would i go get
a [__] donut if it tastes like ass if
it's dry dunkin donuts is done [__] uh
gentlemen's donut my wife just bought it
a couple weeks ago for the kids they
were gonna come over so she got the
three pack the chocolate the cinnamon
and the white when i opened it up it was
so skinny the donut
yeah look like tony bondi's dick tony
bondi's dick the dude on club 38 that
had the long dick but it was skinny like
real skinny like somebody pulled on it
for an hour his brothers pulled on it
that's what the donut looked like when i
was a kid those donuts were thick and i
gotta be honest i broke a half of the
chocolate and i took a bite of [__]
entiments my favorite
if when i was 21 my goal was to [__] the
enterman's building like to drill a hole
in it
[__] the building and then eat it to
death because i [__] loved it
i don't blame you dude i [__] loved
it
and now i can't touch one of those
[__] things i mean the coffee cake is
still god
yeah dude candy when i was going why do
you think i went to the fourth wall
every night because it was next to 7 11
and i would get two chocolate things and
two gummy things towards the end it was
2-3 000 calories
a night just in candy
it's not it's just
can't that's the one thing i miss
i eat my treat now are caramel rice
cakes i eat the [__] out of caramel rice
cakes i ate seven at a time oh yes [__]
must just land in the toilet and stand
up straight like a [__] sky rise and
[__] and now i know why you should i
mean i know you weren't eating rice
cakes but now that i eat healthy i'm
having the big i like when it comes out
of the water goes all the way in the
hole and then comes out of the water i'm
having some good ones now the best is
when you go to wipe your ass and your
knuckles hit the [__] that's when you
know
you're putting some [__] inches on
that [__] toilet you know i've never
had that happen oh my god every once a
month i reach down and i get a little
[__] on my knuckles i gotta get up wash
one hand like a [__]
like a [__] leper i gotta wash one
hand and put cologne on the finger i was
gonna ask you if you watched it i
thought you might
go to your friend or go to mike hey
smell this
no no
smell this you could throw them in jail
now
what i'm saying you can put them in jail
some little guy came up to me and said
smell this what the [__]
you know they could just throw you in
[__] jail now so you can't tell
nobody smell pull my finger they'll
throw you a [__] jail now if you tell
somebody pull my finger like some young
girl in the old days you're like i
pulled my finger you're going to jail
for two [__] years
you don't do that to mercy you don't
fart on mercy
i'd let her uh pull my finger from time
to time i'll blow her fart and ask if
she smelled it and she'll say no
you know
oh that's hysterical
it's amazing how big she is dude i
talked to her on her birthday
she's like a little adult now
doug
it's a different [__] animal okay
that's so awesome people like dog you're
more calm you're more quiet no no i'm
more in shock
i'm walking around in shock i'm walking
for a building to hit me because i know
she's
a year away from her hormones starting
and i know that i mean she's already
like nine going on 13.
she's very mature and [__] i really i'm
having a great time with him listen
right now
i am having a very very very good time
with that and we talk at night i talked
to her yesterday
last night i took up the kickboxing on
the way back she's like dad i don't want
to stay home my [__] mom's got me all
bored and [__] [__] we'll hit the six
o'clock pizza party and call us
so i took over the carlos we had a good
time with her friends you know it's uh
i'm talking to her more she still don't
know
anything about the refill no really no
no she doesn't know anything
she's not on youtube all day i thought
the kids were on youtube all day no
thank god no
no her mother fixed all the computers
and [__] so she can only see like videos
have gone with the wind and [__] like
that no [__]
i don't need some [__] goomba looking
[__] with a big dick showing her
a big dick and then she's
i gotta you know listen man it's so
weird how you
expect something from your children but
you also want to protect your children
i want my daughter to be street savvy
but also for right now
for right now i got a little [__]
shaded just because she don't need that
in her life she don't need to know about
this or that it doesn't have nothing to
do with what she's going for her goal
right now
is to giggle
and what do girls do they want to have
fun
and i've accepted it you know when i was
21 i didn't want nobody just to have fun
[__] you having fun on my dime you know
what i'm saying but now when i have a
daughter and she's [__]
nine going on ten girls just wanna have
fun what am i gonna do yeah she's gonna
have plenty of that later on yeah she's
gonna have plenty of it
she's having the best life i could give
her right now she's got a ton of friends
you know
last night she said to me i don't know
if i want to go to kickboxing mercy what
are your options
there's no school you're going to sit
here like a [__] dunce for the
opportunity because all right two
minutes in the school she's giggling
she's flirting with the boys you know
she knows all the boys there and she
throws them around
it's [__] hysterical she throws them
around and she looks at me and giggles
and winks at me like
she's got a great [__] hip bro over
there so
listen do you still let her kick you in
the leg
yeah from time to time out of work the
leg with the little she got new [__]
uh
shin guards a little harder
the hard plastic ones like the one i got
it's a little harder but it's been a
[__] experience you know lee you look
at
la la worked out the way it was supposed
to
we did everything we can and we ended at
the right time we got off the air at the
right time i think that you were ready
for something new
i was ready for something new and the
timing was perfect at the time it didn't
sound good it was like what the [__] are
we gonna do with our lives but it all
worked out i got to be honest here now
that
i've spoken to like five or six people
the last week and i can tell that
they're moving forward
like people have started moving forward
whatever things they wanted to do with
their business or with their lives
covert put it on hold they're moving
forward with it now that's it the
country's been
75 percent infected would be time to
move on you want to walk around with a
mass god i also got a [__] uh a
doo-wop album you could [__] listen
to you know what i'm saying that's like
50 years ago right now that [__] i'm
walking around with a mask listen take
it off that was three [__] that was
20 years ago that's what it feels like
right now it was 20 [__] years ago
let's move forward it's a [__]
glorified cold you know it's a glorified
cold this will force you to take
vitamins this will force you to eat
better this will force you to get that
one hour of sleep
and uh this is what this break has been
for
to look at your life get healthy we took
a two year [__] break now i'm ready
to sling dick again if you're a hooker
for two years you've been like you know
taking care of your [__] painting it
spraying it putting cbd all in there
it's time to suck dick again and let
loose we're going to sink that man in
the [__] boat and that's it we're
going straight to the [__] world ends
now you told me something a couple weeks
ago that reminded me
you were like you know i don't know
nothing about none all i know is in all
my time in l.a you were the hardest
[__] working guy there and it was
funny because you were a felon and a
[__] piece of [__] and it's the truth
and you know what i've taken a two year
sabbatical from [__] life because i
had to it was time
it was too much you know i didn't take a
[__] breather
it was a 15-year run without the coke
and it was time to
go what the [__] happened and that's
what i've been doing the last two years
is just
evaluating we're two weeks away from
finishing the book
oh that's awesome today we do chapter
2020 and then the next chapters
how it went down me leaving us deciding
to close the podcast you know me seeing
that dude get hit in the head with the
[__] two by four to four by four
me seeing the [__] white dude punch
the black hooker in the face during
black lives matter at cvs on on [__]
lancashire i don't know if i knew that
about that yeah i told you about that
when i went to ces that morning to get
my medication and [__] a white dude
was outside talking to a black chick i
don't know what they were saying
i had no idea i just knew he was a fat
dude talking to a hot little skinny
black chick attending the [__]
morning
but then when i came out they were still
out there and the argument had escalated
and he kept saying where's my wallet
where's my wallet she was sucking this
dick and she pickpocketed them that's
the oldest trick in the book that's when
you get a [__] from a hooker you put
your wallet in the [__] back pocket
because you're sitting on it she can't
pickpocket you if you have it in the
front wall if those chicks will
pickpocket you when you get your dick
sucked you're looking up at god thinking
what happened you're gonna be saying
this is the best thing in the world
why'd you make me a welder she's sucking
away she's [__] picking they could
pickpocket you take a 20 out and put it
back in your wallet that's how good they
are
she just threw it right through his
wallet and [__]
he kept saying where's my wallet as i
was getting the car he just punched her
with her right a straight right to the
jaw she dropped and she started yelling
where's my pant and then that
[__] pimp started coming up on
his little mazda
packed with [__] death row he had
death row in that [__] car
and that's when it was time for me to
leave i didn't even wait for the cops i
didn't wait i could have been a good
samaritan and helped her up that's not
my angle they have cameras yeah we got
cameras at cvs and they weren't going to
prosecute them anyway right now if you
smack somebody in l.a they'll talk you
how to prosecute that's crazy did i was
going to ask you does mercy miss it at
all does she ever say oh i miss la i
miss people there not
a peep
wow
once she came here i never forget when
she first bit into the pizza and her
[__] eyes
it was like somebody hit her in the head
with a two by four she's like i'll never
go back to california
[__] danielle she had one connection she
has two connections to california
a little girlfriend
and she lives in godwood
okay and then her other little
girlfriend
that they were tight with for about a
year they stayed tight on the phone and
[__] and then the mother was supposed to
come to cape may
and call my wife
and my wife waited here all week for the
[__] phone typical la people
my wife was very upset she didn't she
didn't tell mercy that the family was
coming because she had a funny feeling
that they were going to pull a
california [__]
crappy
and that's what they did and
mercy's really tight with that girl
mercy really likes that girl but i tell
you something
the last two or three months she hasn't
said nothing about her in fact i slipped
with her name the other day i said her
name
and she didn't even say no i haven't
spoken to her no she just polished right
through she's it's listen
i was pissed off for a [__] neatly
if you know anything about me i was
really pissed off because
i'm johnny social
i've been trained in being social i've
been social all my life
and when i moved here
between my wife and my daughter they
were social butterflies me
nobody wanted to meet me like i was like
[__]
you know but then i got on the other
side i didn't want i didn't want to
create what i created that i like like
people [__] being my friend because
of comedy i want to i wanted people to
be my friend because of me and i
remember i met a few people and i
remember the neighbor across the street
the pumas
he came to me like we were friends for
about two weeks talking and [__] and one
day he's like hey man
i saw a video here and i remember that
it sucked the energy out of me it was
like somebody kicked me in the stomach
like [__]
my secret is out
you don't like to see like i thought
these people didn't watch comedy they
didn't know anything about podcasts
but i didn't adjust like they did they
were out the box they were going to
parties after a week
meeting people after a week i'm sitting
down there i had to drive all the way to
north bergen to talk to my friends and
whatnot
well i mean i was listening to you on
rogan and i think what you said made a
lot of sense that you know you went from
jersey to colorado to seattle to l.a all
that [__] happened and you don't have i
had a minuscule version of that happen
and i still
like
it still blows my mind that as many
people watched and listened to the
church as they did
like i don't really
understand i understand but i really
don't
that
that people all around the world for 10
years hundreds of thousands millions of
people would ever listen to the podcast
it doesn't really make sense to me
i i i still haven't really
fully accepted that that happened
it's it's it's very funny that right now
i have the joint and the numbers are
maybe
a quarter of what the church did
and it doesn't bother me like i could
sleep at night i'm okay with it because
i didn't know where the church was going
we never really knew what the church was
going we just kept doing it and kept
getting high and kept increasing the
numbers on the edibles
you know we didn't know where the [__]
it was going but
it was big and you look at some of those
youtube numbers they've been stolen and
they've been re-fucking put up so we
don't really have a gauge on what
they've done
right
but now looking back after a year and a
half and not doing it
i'm very proud of the church
yeah hello i'm very proud of the church
when i look at the church now it's like
looking at i love lucy in black and
white
you know that was what a podcast was
then
we tried to
you know do the best we can and
we did the best we can we got to a lot
of people our message
was uh
you know the message that
and the message still continues in
in my life that
doesn't matter what happened to you
doesn't matter what you did
you could always create a second chance
for yourself that's what i always call
the church and the joint the second
chance podcast they're for misfits
they're for people who've been made to
feel like they don't belong guess what
they do belong it was like me for years
man and still
i still feel like i don't belong
as a stand-up i never felt
included
and then as a human being i never felt
included so it just ran with that but
and i know people who listen to it feel
the same way we've never been included
in the big things you know what i'm
saying and yeah i'm friends with joe and
i'm friends with larry and i'm fred's
burt but look at that netflix special
look at those netflix specials and who
they give them to
they have a certain
clientele and i was never one of them i
was never one of them for anything you
know what i'm saying whether it was
chelsea but i kept overcoming and kept
pushing forward you can't worry about
what you don't
accomplish you have to worry about what
you do accomplish
and what's next you know and i think we
did that with the church we really
raised the bar on podcasting as
because it wasn't
an information podcast right it was an
escape podcast go listen
that's what i wanted to create i didn't
want people to sit there and be like
[__]
we can't miss this word because we're
gonna no
it's an escape podcast you put it on for
an hour and a half you smoke a joint and
you take the ride with the more so like
a pink floyd album or
a led zeppelin album i'm not saying i'm
jimmy page or robert plant but
what i'm saying is that's what we were
going for that
tag along i didn't want to go on them be
smarter than you and compete with bill
maher you know bill maher's bill maher
john oliver is john oliver
rogan's rogan and where who the [__] we
are what if we would have put fake [__]
shirts on
i don't think the podcast would have
done that well and that when i see a
podcast that's not doing well
i think a friend of mine i'll check it
out and i'm i'll see that those two
people on that podcast or those three
people or four people
are each trying to be something else if
you keep it to yourself and keep it in
your world and in your lane and what you
talk about
everything will be okay i didn't go on
there even now i don't go on here
talking about vaccines not because i
don't want to compete with rogan because
i don't know anything about that [__]
writing stays up for days reading all
that [__] i don't want to read about
vaccines and mras and
you know but he did and he presents
knowledge to you and that's great but
even when i went on rogan last week it
was a feel-good podcast you weren't
going to learn nothing from that
right but i think
i don't know rogan that well but i think
if ro even if rogan didn't have the
podcast he'd probably be interested in
some of that stuff i think the church
did a great job
of
showing who you were and and we had a
lot of fun but there were some serious
podcasts but it wasn't
it wasn't
to be serious it was just because that's
where the conversation went
it's
it was a it was a window into
into your in my life it was like it was
just it was who we were
for a decade in l.a
you know i love
i love that we kept it
100 like they say we keep it real 100
you know
we're keeping it 100 and [__] now we
just
i like that we never
sailed above who we were that was very
big and i think that was
what people enjoyed from it that we
weren't trying to be anybody but still
to this day i'm not trying to be anybody
i don't give a [__] what you think of me
i'm a [__] douchebag that started
cracking jokes and somebody liked them
and here we are and now
i don't want to do none of that [__]
anymore lee
really i like to come on in and tell
people you know like i'd like to be
not honest yeah honest and go well not
honestly i like to be optimistic
and go yeah you know i'm gonna get on
stage by june i have no [__] idea
i know you don't miss it at all
i spoke to somebody last night from l.a
from my l.a days i spoke to him for
about 45 minutes
i love this guy you know i love him with
all my heart
it was a difficult [__] conversation
i saw what i lost when i left l.a i lost
that
stupid l.a cheddar chatter
that people wrote
i loved this guy last night i almost
hung up on him 10 times
because
it was that [__] hollywood chitta
chatter and it was funny when i got here
i right away
i caught that hollywood chitter chatter
and i tried to get it out of my world
i'm like i'm getting this i got to get
this out of my [__] world you know
and little by little
i did and rogan asked me the other day
he goes you know you don't really you
never really like that hollywood thing
no
no who likes people lying to you
who likes people looking in your face
and telling you one thing then two weeks
later something i didn't like none of
that [__]
you know i saw the when i watched the
super bowl i saw that that
i saw everything i had left behind
you know the super bowl is a [__]
biggest event in the country and all the
celebrities were there
jennifer lopez with those [__] stupid
[__] glasses on
dancing like somebody wants to see that
old [__] that's been worn out
like i said last week she [__]
everybody in that [__] employee
[__] area
you know matt dillon with a [__] uh
mustache looking like joe [__] homo
like he's about to make a porno with six
[__] gay guys in west hollywood that
would and then the rock like here's a
guy that i i don't get anymore
what america you can't tell a dude does
steroids the guy is a walking [__]
contradiction all of them are all those
hollywood guys or a walking [__]
contradiction you didn't see brad pitt
there he was busy getting his dick
sucked by eight [__] illegal
immigrants somewhere in africa he don't
give a [__]
but all that [__] i left that behind
like i didn't want no part that was
[__] to me like how are people
seeing this [__]
that you've eaten more steroids and have
those football players on the field and
you're not even playing [__] football
and you're out there yelling and
screaming you came full circle go [__]
yourself i'm so sick of all that that's
what i got sick of lee and i got sick of
that [__] like in 2018
like there's nothing there's nothing i
hate it more than waiting for somebody
who didn't have a podcast
like somebody who wanted to be a guest
on the show and then have a podcast they
were always late you know i've thought
about moving into a studio up north but
i'm like mike we're going to drive an
hour and this [__] is going to
be a half hour late and i don't even
want to get that started because i'll
throw people out the window now i'm not
in the mood for that [__] if they show
up at all yeah if they show up at all it
was [__] a nightmare even with these
zooms now i'm like you talk to somebody
a week later i can't do tuesday i can't
do i'll go [__] yourself when i called
you last week so i'll just do it myself
i'll come on and talk [__] for a [__]
hour but i just all that [__] had to
disappear from my life it had
you know everything you have to think
about everything just [__] do it like
nike
what are we thinking about what are you
[__] copernicus what is that a
[__] think about they talk and they
want to meet get the [__] out of here
just get on stage write the 10 jokes
and get on [__] stage
right see i would obviously i was never
anywhere close to your level of stand up
i gotta i haven't done it in a few
months i missed doing stand up but i i
never
like i wasn't doing it for a living i
was just doing it for fun and to be
honest what i miss more than actually
doing stand-up is i miss doing with eric
and all those guys out in l.a i miss i
miss that part of it the camaraderie of
stand-up is a beautiful [__] thing
yeah i've been imprisoned that's one
thing that that beats everything by a
mile the camaraderie
of comedy it really is something
when you're all on an even ground
and you're all looking for the same
you're all wanting the same thing
there's nothing like my comedy friends
and i'll never ever forget them that's
like going to [__] jail with four
people
it's like going to vietnam you know it's
that's the camaraderie to go out you
don't think i miss comedy i miss
the simplicity
i miss the waiting all day to do six
minutes
i don't miss the professional side of
comedy right i miss that struggle side
of comedy that
but now it wouldn't be a struggle it
would just be a struggle to get new
material
you think so
yes i can't [__] write comedy anymore
my comedy [__] chops
disintegrated i tried to [__] write
comedy
and every once in a while i come up with
a [__] gen but nah
dude i
i went to hundreds of shows with you i
remember with either you were it's
either you were the priest we were
driving down to that first album
recording he looked over at me said i
don't know what i'm gonna say i have
nothing to say
did one set and i went to number one on
itunes for a month it
i i don't know i think you could do it i
do you miss that do you miss like making
people laugh like that laugh
like when there's a big laugh and i
didn't get that many of them that i miss
listen you always you miss a [__]
everybody misses it
you miss a [__] you know you don't
miss that you're beating you catch after
they suck your dick and swallow now you
gotta take a half hour you beat with
sperm breath
you know you're smelling your [__]
sperm in the end she's telling you about
her life and you know she wants to be a
star and she wants to meet kanye west
you know
oh
jesus christ
is that the freeze pipe which one is
that that's that pipe
you know
what we talking about about
above i've kind of feel like it came
through the screen about missing about
missing getting laughs about missing
comedy
i missed the labs but i don't miss what
comes with it
i gotta hear your ear beating i gotta
hear your story about how you ran over
your mother and you gotta you know i
gotta [__] take a picture and get a
shot like bad breath in my neck or
deodorant
i used to love
i miss little i don't miss those things
i used to love when you would do the
the meet and greets and someone will put
their arm around you like on the early
show and then the late show you would
come back pissed you would be pissing me
onions and [__] how would you like to go
on stage smelling like a [__] onion
knowing it's not you
it's not you i don't mind smelling like
a [__] onion and dealing with it
number one i never go out of my way they
smell like a [__] onion i always try
to wash your armpits and your ass my car
smells like pure straight
rotten [__] ass
this morning i was thinking i gotta go
not blow this thing apart i gotta go
armor all this blow this apart and take
that little place where my [__] sits
and like [__]
chop it up with [__]
cut it out
yeah you just need a new a new seat
jesus christ
you dare enter this [__] house
[__]
i love it so you're coming down in two
weeks
absolutely not this weekend and not the
following weekend but the weekend after
that because terry's leaving the weekend
after that for nashville okay i'll have
to
i'll tell you my girlfriend's kid has a
birthday but i'm sure i'm sure it'll
work out
i have to look at this at the calendar
but i can't wait to come down bring the
[__] kid we're gonna take them skinny
dipping the whole [__] thing here oh
you would lose their mind these
i
every i've been with her for seven
months
the stuff that i see now i can't imagine
doing what you used to do when mercy was
that young if like six in the morning
they're running the four-year-old i
shaved my beard the four-year-old yelled
at me and said i don't like lee's face
go back to your room
i don't
yeah oh she doesn't she she doesn't [__]
around i don't know how
i don't know how you do it man that's
i'm with her a couple days a week
doing it all day every day
and then you're going out to the store
till two in the morning
jesus like i said i had to pick a
[__] flag
and that's why i picked the flag of my
family for right now
lifa right now she needs me she's at an
age where
she likes to come home to me
yeah absolutely she really had a hard
time last wednesday when i left for the
day
she had a hard time that morning when i
left and that night when i got home she
was [__] sleeping on my chair waiting
for me oh that's nice yeah so
that whole game has changed
um
we've all changed and i'm happy that
we did what we did every month and i
look at you the other day when i saw
that video
i can't tell you i got to be honest i
brought a tear to my tiana like i was
very happy for you i'm very happy for
what you've done
i knew you always had it if i would have
checked on you now and you would have
been heavier than when you left i don't
think i'd be talking to you no more
because i knew you were a month away
from giving up but you didn't give up
liam you look great
thank you man and you got a lot of great
things happening in your future who
knows maybe one day when i quit the
podcast you and michael get together and
start up a [__] production company
and be the two biggest [__] on
the podcasting arena right now you know
but let's do it no i i appreciate it man
i uh
i did there was a few months where i i
still ate the way i did but
i i it's been
it's come it's crazy it's gonna be like
a year and a half now whatever it's been
since we left and it's
i appreciate it i miss you i miss you
i'm excited to meet you i'm excited to
meet mike and all that stuff but it's um
because it is it's scary there's a lot
of people you know whether you lose a
job you break up you got it's a scary
thing this to basically start over
but it
i don't know it's so far things have
turned out pretty well let's hope really
[__] well have i considered that tell
you the name of this podcast episode is
you got to hit rock bottom
before you start pointing those missiles
up and you did that you
and you didn't hit rock bottom in this
professional way you hit rock bottom as
a physical way you know physically yeah
i think that
just everything about l.a the only thing
that made you forget about what the [__]
you're doing is stuff in your goddamn
face yeah i had the same problem that
way brother it wasn't just you you know
me and my wife only miss one thing
yum yum [__] donuts
that's one thing all three of us have
come to conclusion that
we do miss yum yum [__] doughnuts
they're they're pretty there's no
doughnuts by you i just haven't i can't
have a doughnut there's no doughnuts
great donuts i'm not in search of a
[__] donut it's not like i drive
around looking for a doughnut i'm sure
like in time you do
oh there's a place called rocco's in
worcester that i just i look on
instagram all day i'll bring you someone
i'd come and visit it's supposed to be
[__] outrageous but i don't oh
i love donuts
dude i would eat a dozen donuts in a day
i would go to yum yum you you saw that
girl no that girl knew me at yum yum
donuts
she was great
that girl has probably gotten robbed
eight times since we [__] left they
got 22 mexicans in there now one with a
beretta one dressed like pancho villa
with the bullets across his [__]
chest
no that's the name of this podcast
because
i think i hit rock bottom at an
emotional level that's when i was all
[__] up and the xanax and everything
and i think that you were just lost on
what
you know you had to do you go home at
night it was kind of a sad existence for
both of us to be honest here you were
working a lot of hours we both were
putting a lot of hours we didn't even
enjoy life
now we're enjoying life
on our [__] terms so i'm happy you
came on today thank you for the happy
birthday video thank you i'm happy the
hummus tasted like the skin on my dick
the turtleneck
i'll bring you something if you try a
little bit it's good just don't eat the
whole shrimp [__] i wouldn't try that
[__] if you put [__] [__] juice in
it you understand me you tried ranch you
got to try a little hummus but i tried
ranch when they had the cinnamon and the
[__] hot sauce up in there yeah
sriracha yeah yeah i'll bring you spicy
hummus no i don't want no spicy hummus
all right take that hummus and put it on
your toes and see how it sniffs
you're gonna smell it and go [__] this
smells like the [__] in 7-eleven where i
go to get lottery tickets you're still
playing the lottery
[__] never win
never doug you're the [__] mush of
mush they give you the ticket ripped up
when you push the lottery he don't even
push it into the computer he knows it's
two dollars that goes straight in his
pocket i found that we placed the same
bet on i
was on draftkings when i was in philly
because it's legal there that that that
cincinnati plus four was nice that was a
good bet you liked that huh
yeah that was a good one
did you take the under two
no i see i i i [__] up i did the
cincinnati plus four but the night
before i did the ufc and [__]
basically lost half so i i ended up
winning 60 bucks but i lost my first
fight in the ufc but then i came back
strong with tia with the dude who drinks
out of the shoe hi say i want that one
that was that one they got a profit
boost from [__] draftkings
and then sunday i bet that i lost all my
props but [__] cincinnati and the
under was strong representing draftkings
today even though a lot of people ain't
betting right now you'll be back for
march
kings is madness
so
we'll be back for march [__] madness
but i love you
countdown begins we'll make some videos
when you're down here and show these
[__] what it's like to eat an
empire szechuan
because i know that's the number one
place you want to go to we'll get you a
little general child
yes get you a [__] szechuan
twice cooked pork yes delicious we'll
get a couple egg rolls seafood dumplings
okay get a couple sushi rolls we'll mix
the flags my beliefs
you don't know what it's like to eat
some nice [__] twice cooked pork and
inhale a nice [__] soft crab shell
sushi
oh dipped in wasabi you feel your
[__] puckering up like [__]
lindsay lohan's [__]
[__] lips i thought i was banned from
eating sushi he said i was too boring
eating sushi oh yeah yeah because you
eat like [__] you eat [__] you eat
california rolling two pieces of shrimp
you couldn't even die you can't even get
like a [__] sushi disease right
japanese remember that lady a couple
weeks ago waited but went to an oil you
could eat japanese sushi place and she
[__] and went to the hospital and they
interviewed and she's like i'm going
back to eat again
you [__] jamok that [__]
standstill
sushi that's been there for two hours
that's what you
but when you come here i'm gonna turn
you into some soft shell crab okay some
[__] octopus tongue
okay [__] whale [__] [__] they
have whale [__] these chinese people
eat right here in the east coast you
know what i'm saying not that [__]
i'll tell you the sushi at sushi dan
was world-class bro it was expensive as
[__]
you went and then got raped for lunch 50
for lunch by yourself yeah [__] my
wife's gonna kill me but god damn
this is they have a good happy hour here
if anyone ever goes back then dogs
or something happy they got the spicy
tuna yeah oh yeah
they got a nice [__] temporary
temporary whatever the [__] it is
tempura yeah that's 13 [__] weight
watcher points oh yeah it's [__]
fried just a piece of shrimp
a shrimp is zero
i know you got 13 [__] 14 points so
if you put a couple [__] yellow tail
and some masagi whatever that [__]
australian sauce you're [__] over the
point limit so i had to stop and it's
true they put sugar in that rice oh i'm
sure they [__] that makes it sticky is
not good for you i just read that and
then somebody
told me about it so
hey what do you want from me and i'm
saying we're just trying to steal that i
love you [__] i'll see you in
three weeks not this weekend
not the following weekend march 4th but
the following if you can if not we'll do
the following
okay i'll i'll let y'all do a podcast on
sunday we'll take a right to empire
szechuan and you get in the car with mom
and shoot up i'll give you a couple abx
[__] edibles for the drive i'll stop
every 20 minutes to write your suicide
note
i can't wait
i love you stay black have a great day
thank you for coming on the joint
[__] i love you and i miss you
love and miss you too buddy thank you
mike
you got it tarzan
hit it mike
yo we're back i'm happy you [__]
enjoyed it man it was great to see him
we had some great laughs you know i
could uh
you guys see that when we're together
we get right back to it
listen a lot of people say to me you
know my wife said to me one day she goes
would you ever consider bringing it back
i know not in a million [__] years
you see seinfeld bringing back his show
no and as much as whatever i think about
seinfeld i tell you he's very smart and
he knows that
you can never you know led zeppelin
should come back i think they would
never [__] be even a third of what
they were
because you can't capture lightning in a
[__] bottle even if kurt cobain had
come back today if kurt walked out of a
[__] casket you think nirvana would
be jamming [__] no it's it's
it's different
it was a certain time and a place and
time
where that was all great i really
enjoyed my open mic days i really
[__] did and now sitting here after
two years of just sitting here and
thinking jesus christ the best part of
my career
was my open mic i missed that
camaraderie and the you know i miss all
that and
i wasn't commenting on a professional
level that i missed by no means i don't
miss theaters and comedy clubs i miss
doing the open mics
where you went and you split an order
onion rings that was your [__] dinner
that was your dinner that was a home
ball you need 30 grams of protein [__]
you
i lived on a half order of [__] onion
rings that's why i got the 450 [__]
pounds but that's what you did
and that was the beauty of it that
camaraderie nobody cared about
being [__] on tv nobody cared about
having a number one cd all you cared
about
was being funny that's what i ended up
missing
and in time i think that i'll miss that
so much i'll just go and do open mics or
something and get a [__] couple
laughs and go home just as a hobbyist i
do miss that you know lee asked me do
you miss it
i do miss that part of it but i don't
miss everything that else that [__]
comes with it so that's where i'm at
guys i'm happy uh i hope you enjoyed the
podcast this week i'm happy we're on
[__] spotify oh [__]
and that's it and that's that i love you
[__] thank you for watching
this week have a great week thank you
for all the birthday wishes and we're on
[__] next week it's [__]
march so stay black have a great week
and i'll see you [__] monday
morning tip top magoo
love you
all right i want to thank lisa
i want to thank mike but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for always having
my back the joint is brought to you by
expressvpn listen you've heard me talk
about how important it is to have a vpn
to protect your online privacy
especially like me you like to see
creepy things but choosing a vpn you
trust is just as important you know
uncle joey
only i only bring you what i believe in
and express vpn is the best ppn on the
market point blank
period expressvpn does not log into your
activity line
lots of cheap vpns sell your data
advertisers but not expressvpn it's
faster than ever you could stream in hd
with zero buffering and it's simple you
don't need no technical skills just fire
up the app tap one button to connect and
tip top magoo you're looking at people
jumping off cliffs and [__] bangkok
and i'm not just saying this business
insider the verge and others rate
express vpn the number one bp in the
world so what the [__] are you waiting
for protect yourself with vpn and use
the one i trust expressvpn.com
joey today and i'm gonna get you an
extra three months on a one-year package
who's better than you uncle joey nobody
that's expressvpn
joey visit expressvpn
for more info the joint is also brought
to you by
cbd lion listen with me for three years
i use it every [__] single day in
different facets of my life sometimes i
put the tape on for my knee sometimes i
take the
whatever the liquid that you put under
your tongue tremendous
i take the gummies to sleep you know the
bath ball when i'm feeling sore
tremendous so do yourself a favor
go to cbdline.com and read the third
party lab results you're going to be
blown the [__] away
how you lived without cbd all these live
i don't know even whoop ask you at the
end of the day when you wake up in the
morning did you use your cbd products
today what does that tell you
cbdline.com
press joey and i'm gonna get you 20 off
the liberty house the joint is also
brought to you by a tremendous
tremendous product liquid iv
if you're thinking about getting that
summer body
listen make sure your gym bag has some
liquid iv in it why because it's
tremendous i love it since i got covered
i learned to drink it and oh my god the
cherry the grape
the [__] passion fruit
the uh the pina colada they will rock
your world one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water hydrates you faster than
water alone anything else on the market
it's made with premium ingredients
it's vegan non-gmo and and gluten-free
dairy-free
soy-free it's just free and their
support and frontline work is to stay
healthy with over 19 million servings
donated so far you know liquid iv they
care and that's why i love them grab
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
it's going to cost you some money so
what i'm going to do is and just for the
joint listeners i'm going to get you 25
off that price sticker when you go to
liquidity.com use code joey
that's
liquidity.com use code joey that's 25
off anything you order whether it's the
whether it's the immune the energy or
the regular and i'm going to get you 25
off anything when you use
promo code joey at
liquidity.com experience better
hydration
liquid iv.com
today use promo code joey i want to
thank liquid iv i want to thank
expressvpn
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
better help
blue chew for a big dick
and lucy for helping me stop smoking i
love you [__] have a great week
and i also want to thank honey
for making my brain sharp again i love
you [__] have a great week and
i'll see you monday the 28th
tip top magoo stay black
[Music]
you